okay welcome everyone to our second
lecture today and I'm Grand Master
Mushin Akopian and I'll be showing you
one of my games today from the recently
finished US Championship and it was a
very exciting event and I had a very
good tournament tie for first and
finished second after playing two
playoff playoff games matches so this
game is actually the playoff game
Armageddon game against grandmaster
Alexander Linderman I'm playing with the
black pieces so c4 e 5 by the way he has
45 minutes I have 30 minutes but I have
the draw odds which is if the game ends
in a draw I advance so but he has the
white plus 15 minutes extra time so that
was the procedure how we got here and
now he played the c4 in the main
tournament the last round he also played
c4 against me and he got a good position
I didn't play really well in that
opening so I was slightly worse and but
he repeated it which I thought maybe he
would do something different so I looked
it up and prepared this new response
against it
c-45 in general my opinion is if your
opponent plays c4 the best move is a5
and you should play the best by studying
of course so you have some ideas what to
do except first move now see 45 96 this
was a very very nice game for me and it
was really easy to play and everything
was just you know coming along somehow
very easy in this game even though it
was a big game lots of pressure so he
goes Knight c3 Knight f6
g3 c6 Bishop g2 Bishop c5 this is a
they're very there are many different
ways how to develop in this position for
black but this is a you know one of my
favorite setups here just nice odd
Bishop on c5 and white can put a knight
on f3 in the system or you can play III
which Alex did so I play d6 9bt to
castle castle place d3 I play castle
castle h6 idea behind this move is I
want to control the g5 square so his
bishop cannot come in some positions I
also want to have the escape square lift
for my King so he plays a three idea
behind this one is to play before I play
a three
before attacking the bishop bishop goes
back to a7 Bishop b2
now he's gained some space advantage on
the queenside and he's got the pieces
developed and also try to play d4 try
play rook b8 this is a prophylactic idea
to protect b7 so when I move my knight
and a bishop the b7 pawn will be no
longer hanging so that's that it could
repeat and make sure the b7 one is
protected so he plays d4 and he wants to
play d5 now and gain more space and
basically come in into my territory
so I cannot allow him to do that so I
exchange first he could take back with a
knight
this is a playable response I would
probably exchange and play something
similar where I did in the game Bishop
f5 like if I go see it I will take take
Bishop f5 rook e8 c6 something like this
so he goes here
now from here on until the end of the
game I want you to fight all the moves
that I played one good move after
another until the end but it wasn't a
very long game you you'll see so first
here if you look at my pieces here you
can see that some of these pieces could
be placed on a better squares I can
improve them so they're a little bit
better developed so first of all which
piece we should try to develop here and
question is where bishop where
g4 gets kicked out by h3 and question is
where we achieve yes f5 but d7 is better
which which square bishop looks more
active controlling more squares of
course no question
the move is Bishop f5 here and now you
stop the Queen from coming in which is
very important Queen now cannot come to
d3 because Queen would have been well
placed here but now we are controlling
it so he cannot come here now equals c5
he's trying to shut down my bishop he
does have some space advantage on that
side of the board but my pieces are just
well placed
now one more developing move need
one more piece you can try to develop
here actually a few more pieces though
absolutely in general remember when you
see an open file and you have a look
that the first idea comes into mind put
the rook on an open file and here
there's no difference there is an open
file and we want to control that open
file okay yeah we control it
now he went rogue c1 developing his rook
now continue
always make sure in the early stages of
the game that you look for the pieces
that are not developed and try to
develop these pieces it's a possibility
but then you're kind of blocking the
rooks you know so you don't want to
unless you really need to put a queen
there and then block the rooks the
communication between the rocks of
course there is no reason why not to put
the Queen on d7 so let's just do that
Queen d7 belongs there in some point yes
buddy place 9 F 4 so I developed my
pieces and he also developed his I have
a slight lead in development because my
opponent made a lot of pawn moves he
made a lot of a lot of panels I have a
slight lead in development
and now I want to improve one of my
pieces in fact my goal is in some point
to be able to get the bishop in right I
cannot play this game with a bishop
locked in on a seven I got to find a way
to get this bishop in in the game at
some point so I need to find some ideas
how I can try to bring the bishop back
Bravo excellent 97 now bring in the
Knight to g6 in Sandpoint exchange the
active night and also trying to play c6
at the right moment
he plays Queen b3 he is trying to fight
for the d5 score he's got a lot of
pressure on d5 and he also has a strong
bishop on this diagonal I would like to
have a little bit more control and
neutralized his ideas which Moore will
do that absolutely c6 controlling the d5
square and now blocking the bishop now
he went look fe1 developing his last
piece
now what should I do here you don't want
to commit you know if you play d5 it's
like you closed everything you committed
it that you know and you know he will
try to play for b5 it will be I think
you will be maybe slightly better
pressing
pawn takes pawn but he takes pawn takes
pawn and now my quit queen is going to
get into some trouble here
now g6 attacking the knight he took the
problem for my opponent he's like
looking at the position he's like he's
got no plan here no good plan and he
needs to try to play this position for
the win remember he has more time and
white pieces so he's trying to win but
he has no good plan in this position to
play for a win that's the worst thing it
is better to be worse but have some idea
some tricks but here there are no tricks
no plan like how he can try to win this
very difficult that's why he actually
made a bad decision you will see now so
he made a few bad moves here but but
here it's just black is very comfortable
perhaps maybe black is slightly better
here actually so he took yeah this was
not a good decision first of all he gave
me the open file and he's exchanging
down and I can get my bishop in at some
point but here the his move is of course
it was an oversight he had an idea in
mind but he just missed completely
missed my idea this was his idea to play
d5 I mean he's trying to open up the
position while he can so his bishops
will be sharp opening up the light
square Bishop opening up the dark square
bishop but
now this is very important moment here
you have to start calculate all the
captures all the possibilities here
pawn capture c5 I absolutely agree with
that idea because that helped me to open
up my bishop my bishop is opening up now
if it takes back I just go Bishop c5 so
he takes here takes on c6 don't rush
don't rush this is a playoff game here
for the title I mean you know I have
been working hard for two weeks for this
you know I can't just throw queen bee to
you know slow down tink this is the
final moment of this tournament your
Queen d2 not going to be too effective
with the locked in Bishop you know so
you know you probably want to do that
move win huh B takes c6 right of course
the pawn is dangerous what we do
eliminate it now he's not going to take
back with the spot because I just take
back with the bishop so that doesn't do
too much so it was 94 activating the
night and putting pressure so just
activate the night and now he's putting
pressure on c5 he wants to take back
with a knight here but this is the
moment well you need to find a strong
idea that I did to be able to try to
attack actually later on I analyze there
was another mood I was probably winning
easily but I still think my move was a
good move here to play
that's what I did now some of engines
were saying this is even better at the
game but it's just a human movie see
foreign I mean CB h you just win another
pawn it's just the same thing
but you know I like c4 I like to see
four I mean at that point
so he took if you look at the position
it seems like who all my pawns are weak
on a queen side and he's about just to
start taking those pounds off but I have
something I have something in this
position that he missed that I can try
to take advantage of now
I could have played Queenie - yes Queen
- was a possibility sacrifice let's
calculate then let's calculate the
sacrifice see if it works exactly
because you know I I saw the idea I felt
like it's going to work but I had to
work make sure work everything out you
know because you know just at the end
you know you have to make sure when you
do these things it's it's it's good it's
winning yeah but you know the best way
to play for the joy is to play for the
win a lot of players when they get in
these positions display of games they
think I just need to make a draw you
know and tighten up and try to defend
you know and that's not a very that's
not a good way to make a draw I've done
that mistake myself before you know like
many years ago just you know try to play
solidly image but then then it's like
you get into trouble you just play
normal you just play normal chess and
you know you make good moves play for a
win and opportunities will come it's
just easier because in some point you
might have some reflect real ideas but
don't play too tight in this kind of
that's the key
what is friend especially spine
yeah I mean if he puts his knight on c5
I'm in big trouble here if he shuts down
my dark square Bishop here next book by
putting the knight on c5 I'm gonna be in
trouble so he wants to put the knight
out there but takes of course he has to
take if he goes to the corner I just go
Bishop III and followed that up with 94
9f2 and just too slow so he took I mean
if he goes you will just lose anyway
come in now you cannot go to f1 because
of we should decree lose the Queen and
this is just the checkmate so it has to
go to g1
yeah but tix yeah you know you Queen
comes back and we could lose don't rush
when you're attacking don't exchange
pieces activate them make sure your
pieces come into his territory tink tink
don't rush of course when you got one
piece on the second round
what's the other thing you got to think
about put another one right to start
keep on attacking because second rack is
very important it will always be
something that you can attack so you go
Ruki - and now you attack on the second
rank what is it going to do the bishop
is hanging of course the obvious move
that we need to calculate this Queen
takes c6 if it does that who can show me
quickly the checkmate here excellent
should wait
nice work and if he goes here Bishop f1
what do you do that's a very strong
chick yep
excellent so not too many things you can
do here there's no other way to protect
it so he took the pawn now I'm down on a
piece clearly down a piece but I have a
winning attack here there might have
been another way to finish this off but
I kind of like the way that I played
here because it's a you know logical
what I did was very logical and you got
to keep it logical in this kind of
positions
rook takes pawn is possible but okay he
will defend your threat of queen F to
Queen d4 maybe you know you you need to
do something that will keep his king
completely lonely with no defenders
protecting him and king h1 is there a
good follow up
what's wrong with Queen III text
checkmate in three but other way one
mistake one mistake you know I saw this
line actually that was my first idea to
exchange the bishops going this way but
I realized no I need my bishop
I need my lights could be sharp enough
to control this once I realized that I
already knew the first move but I did
look at Bishop before but then I
acquitted I looked at Bishop e4 here and
I discovered that quickly that in a same
concept I get made it actually Queen a5
Roxy but once I saw it this this this is
the only thing that he can do basically
here you know if I blunder he can get
back into the game and maybe you win but
if you find a correct move now black is
winning victory is yours
thank you
quint xg4 don't rush don't rush this is
too important game to play quickly okay
let me ask you this question it will be
very easy after this which piece is
holding the position for white
if the bishop wasn't there isn't that
just a easy mate check on ji to check on
edge tomato ng - right so that Bishop is
the piece that is holding the position
together but we were putting the wrong
piece only for that was a problem of
course of course not only for now
completely shutting down this Bishop and
threatening check check check mate
checkmate in three thread the checkmate
in three now threatening and most
important thing is now this idea doesn't
work because we got a bishop here so
check and here remember when I played h6
earlier you might have thought why did
he play h6 here you know for this kind
of ideas I played h6 not like when you
really need a lot of people they just
wait you know wait wait wait wait and
then I think okay I'll do it when I
really need it but when you get into
positions like this you're not going to
have that time to do it so sometimes you
make this loop move in advance actually
oftentimes you do that okay
so make your looped flight square early
don't wait like for the last moment okay
so this h6 was crucial otherwise all
these lines would fail for me
yeah yeah I mean he didn't develop the
bishop that way this time but it was
just extremely useful to have this pawn
here okay let's let's focus guys
queen bee for now he plays now actually
sorry baby should before he is
controlling the f2 square at least so
there is no checkmate here immediately
hook check he can't go to the corner
because of check and checkmate he cannot
do that he goes here again keep in mind
draw is enough here so if draw is enough
what can you do first before you start
calculating a win repeat because if he
takes checkmate right so I go check he
goes here so I have a draw I did yeah
but not often you will see people play
for a win in this kind of situations but
I just you know I just say you know I
must be able to calculate three moves
you know I know I'm meeting him so it
wouldn't make sense to agree to draw in
a position that is just completely won I
just sat down I had time I just
calculate double check triple check
everything and just you know go for it's
a mate you know so I didn't see a point
of taking a draw but a lot of times
people take draws in this situation I
don't know I just didn't feel like
taking a draw because I thought I played
a good game you know why should I take a
draw huh
even though it's enough and Alex went
here and he said draw and you know you
probably saw the video that movement it
was funny but I say no no actually he
thought I just want to make a draw here
he said draw I'm like no no let's make a
move first so he played his move I'm not
thinking I'm taking my time I calculated
for you know I don't know two three
minutes here double-check everything
make sure it's safe and secure and went
for a win the game ends in three moves
here checkmate in three basically happen
one two three
of course go for it okay I have to
calculate this move the only problem is
one check he has I go here no checks
thanks to the bishop again right so it
doesn't have that so he now I want to go
check here and he went Queen c2 and
check waiting to I can win his queen
here I better could do better than that
check
checkmate yes well that's how it ended
unfortunately this was not enough to win
the tournament because there was another
guy that I had to play that the same day
you know and yeah next opponent was come
ski and he had a little bit of Thai
break it was we had same points all
three of us myself Alex and gotta come
ski but he had a better tie break
because the head-to-head he had defeated
Alex in a tournament and that was the
try break determining so against me he
was a draw but he'd beat Alex so he had
a better tie break so that's why he
didn't play this so he was just waiting
for the winner of this match to play in
the final yeah he only got him because
me and Alex drew in the last round of
the regular tournament and it was just
you know I missed I missed a good chance
there Alex said some advantage in the
opening he was it was very interesting
game so but yeah but it's it's in chess
it happens you know some guys drew and
another guy wins catches up and he wins
in a playoff unexpectedly you know
because council was never leading the
tournament so I was tough but this is
the you know okay okay great
any questions about this game I mean do
you understand how now to play against
the English just so this was a showing
you my game and also helping you to
learn to play against the English okay
no but really you don't need to just
study by a book about this line just you
know just logically just you know if you
remember how I did this
just remember the setup you know this is
the setup you're aiming for you know
even with a knight on f3 even if he has
this position let's say knight on f3
pawn on d3 it's same setup in up before
you go Bishop back on a 7 and remember
this key idea rugby 8 a very strong move
is rugby 8 then you can start moving the
knight back and not go back to g6 usual
a c6 Bishop out Queen d7
oh that was a different game against
Alexei meum I mean but that was just
completely different I wish I don't know
why I didn't play this in a regular
tournament because maybe I would get
this but I don't know it's just so much
easier to play this compared to the
other line that I did okay excellent
you